their excellencies president of ukraine
vladimir zelinsky and the president of
the european commission were sold upon
the line
statement by the president of ukraine
thank you very much
is
i
ukraine foreign
um
foreign
foreign
yes
is
foreign
[Music]
uh
um
please keep helping us
statement by the president of the
european commission
thank you very much vladimir thank you
very much for having me here
and let me at the very beginning
express my condolences for the families
the children
the innocent people that have been
attacked today by russia at the train
station
it is appalling it is horrible it's a
nice nightmare and i really want to say
that our thoughts are with those
families
and with those poor people
indeed i started my day today with a
visit to butcher
because
being in butcher and seeing what has
happened
you can tell that our humanity was
shattered
in budja
and it is right and just that the world
has voted to suspend russia from the
human rights council
this war has a challenge for the entire
international community
and this is indeed a very decisive
moment by now it is a moment where we
have to decide and where we have to
fight for
the question to be answered
will genius devastation
be winning
or will it be humanity that is
prevailing
will
autocracy
be dominant or will democracy
be the long-term dominant
winner
or will the right of might be
the rule
or will it be the rule of law and this
is what is at stake in this war it is a
war yes that russia unleashed against an
innocent ukraine but it's much much more
than that on top it is these big
questions that will be decided in this
war so your fight is also our fight
and i'm here in kiev with you today to
send a very strong message that the
european union is by your side we stand
by your side this is the message that
diavolotomy i want to bring to you but
also to the ukrainian people
we have discussed
a lot of
uh practical topics how we can step up
the european support for ukraine and let
me be clear
we can never match the sacrifice
of the ukrainian people never can we
match that
but we are mobilizing our economic power
to make putin pay a very very heavy
price
we have as you said imposed five waves
of unprecedented sanctions against
russia
and we are already preparing the next
wave we are now moving into a system of
rolling sanctions
and these sanctions are biting hard
if you look at the exports in goods to
russia they have fallen almost by 71
inflation is now by 20 that is rising in
russia
business confidence in russia is at the
lowest level since 1995
and the best and brightest minds are
leaving russia together with more than
700 private companies rightly so who are
leaving russia
on top of this
member states have already frozen
225 billion euros of private russian
assets
in the european union since the
beginning of the war so
if you look at that russia will descend
in economic financial and technological
delay decay
while ukraine
is marching towards a european future
this is what i see
we stand with you
as you defend your country and this is
my second point indeed ukrainian people
are holding up the torch of freedom
for all of us
the european union is sending weapons to
your country
we have allocated almost 1 billion euros
from the european peace facility to
support the ukrainian armed forces and
more will come later on the high
representative will present that
with this support to the brave ukrainian
soldiers fighting for ukraine's freedom
we want to underline that you are
fighting for all of us
the third topic that we have been
discussing
was indeed strengthening our financial
support for ukraine today we are
delivering around about 1 billion euros
of support
this sum consists of three different
pillars
it is as we speak the transfer of
120 million euros to budget support
we will on top we make available 330
million euros from the emergency package
now and we have discussed
that the third pillar is accelerating
the second half of the macro financial
assistance worth 600 million euros
the first fourth topic that we have been
discussing was the ukrainians
refugees as they seek refuge within our
borders and i promise you volodymir
we will take good care of them
until they can safely return home
and home that means home to a free
and independent and prosperous ukraine
we will make sure that they have access
to housing schools medical care and work
because the brave people of ukraine
deserve nothing less
therefore together with prime minister
justin trudeau of canada we are
convening tomorrow a pledging event in
warsaw
we call the campaign stand up for
ukraine
we will mobilize support for people
fleeing the war inside ukraine so the
internally displaced people as well as
those outside ukraine
and this campaign is yet another proof
that ukraine's cause today is the
world's cause
of course this is only for short term
right now the support therefore we have
also been discussing a long-term
reconstruction fund
and i very much liked your idea of
twinning
regions cities
businesses
to support the reconstruction of ukraine
last but not least we are with you as
you dream of europe
the vladimir my message today is very
clear ukraine belongs to the european
family
we've heard your request loud and clear
and today we're here to give you a first
positive answer
in this envelope
dia volodomir there is an important step
towards eu membership
the questionnaire that is in here is the
basis for our discussion
in the coming weeks
it is where your path towards europe and
the european union begins
let me promise
you for this question here that i will
hand over to you in a moment
a question here of course has to be
answered these are questions that then
form a opinion of the european union as
a recommendation to the council
we stand ready 24 hours seven days a
week to support you in filling out this
questionnaire we know a lot about each
other because we've been working
together so intensively over the last
years
so it will be not as usual a matter of
years to form this opinion but i think a
matter of weeks if we work closely
together
so for you
thank you so much i want to give you
that this is
the question
we'll be ready with answers
ursula in one week
thank you thank you president
don't don't be afraid for the
questionnaire you know to get uh
uh jam on a chair we also have to fill
in a lot of questions
i'm sure it will be
very important for you yes
thank you very much and thank you
president for giving me the flow
president i am really touched for what
i've seen
for what uh i heard
for what i felt today
certainly we are
there are two two words to describe
what's happening in ukraine one word is
failure
the big failure of the russian army that
hasn't been able to overcome your
courage
another word is horror
the heart of the civilians being
attacked
being killed
in an indiscriminate way
so we have in the presence of
war crimes
and
we will help you
we will have the prosecutor
ukrainian prosecutor
to present the proofs in front of the
international
criminal court
our mission here in ukraine our advisory
mission
was working before the war
will deploy their effective their means
their tools their capacity that
technical
in order to support you
and we have also located seven million
euros to support you in this task
our delegation will come back to this
i think it's an important news to
announce today
our delegation is coming back
the european union is coming back to
give
and i'm sure that other delegations an
embassy from member state will follow
and the third issue we think it's
important to stress
since you are fighting for us
as the president vanderlian has said
the least thing that we can do
is to give you arms
you have got to got a lot of applauses
you have been in many parliaments in the
european union
and you got a lot of support and a god
of approaches
but you need arms arms arms
we have a located one billion euros
and i hope that in a couple of days we
will be able to allocate 500 million
more
and we will do everything in order
that these resources will be tailoring
your needs
to provide you with the arms you need to
fight to resist
and to win
thank you thank you so much
i'm lorenzo ateneze from anza italian
press agency president von der lion
your goal is to submit ukraine's
applications for eu membership to the
council this summer
once ukraine enter in europe if there's
still war at this point the
confrontation between europe and russia
will be
inevitable are you ready for this and
the question
for president zielinski
about debts and tortures russia talks
about fake news
you're willing to face international
investigation on each side that will
definitely clarify the world and put the
end to the pro-russian conspiracy
to the
prom
to the peoples
i am deeply convinced that ukraine will
win this war democracy will win this war
freedom will win this war
and the right of every country to shape
its own future
and thus we will work together with
ukraine
to rebuild ukraine
and rebuild ukraine means massive
investment and reforms and this will
form and forge the past towards the
european union
foreign
federation
foreign
foreign
foreign
me
ukraine i have a question
to president van der lan
regarding our let's say pass towards
membership
some assessment
says that
we can expect a decision on
our candidacy status even
this summer i mean
during the summit in june would you
share that assessment is it feasible uh
to guess that and also it is important
that uh
do you expect that we can get candidacy
while hostilities are still here so is
it dependent i mean not membership but
just candidacy and maybe you can say
that uh starter of negotiation is
dependent of
seas of hostilities or we can just go
forward not waiting for for russia to
withdraw thank you very much
perhaps one or two sentences on
the process
how it normally goes
so after a an application
the council decides to task the
commission to form an opinion this
normally takes years
here it took weeks
and
then the commission develops the
so-called questionnaire and in a process
back and forth this questionnaire is
filled so that there's a clear picture
of what the state of play in the country
is and whether it fulfills for example
the copenhagen criterias
this also takes normally years
and we have committed ourselves
to work together now on this very
important step
to draw and design the state of play of
the country and many many detailed
questions are in there so it's not only
one question that is determining the
outcome of this
opinion many questions are to be uh
answered we want to work hand in hand to
fill out this questionnaire to draw the
picture to paint the picture of this
country and uh its path towards europe
and then the opinion is basically a
recommendation that comes from the
commission towards the council the
council then decides um
over the next steps so i would give
ourselves a chance an opportunity to
work on that now
with also the knowledge as i just said
that this is an unusual path that
ukraine is going
ukraine has whatever the outcome is a
long period
an intensive period of reconstruction
ahead of it
because russia brutally destroys
infrastructure livelihoods
and cities
and therefore in this process we want to
reach out to really work with you to
reform to build up to reconstruct and
this will determine in a positive way
the path towards the european union
wait for your mic please
kathryn eichendorf from uh german tv set
af mr president my question is um what
is the most important request that you
had to ausla fonder line and did you
achieve that goal do you think
foreign
[Music]
oh
foreign
around certain sanctions
um
um
beginning
part of your question as you see we are
very um we are working on it and an
accession process always takes of course
legal steps and work that has to be done
and here
is the proof of a very successful
cooperation uh what that matter is
concerned
you're right with the sanctions um the
five waves or packages of sanctions are
very much biting their heart
and they are smart because they hit
russia much more than they hit us
what we also see is that of course
russia is
moving trying to create loopholes or to
circumvent the sanctions
therefore it is of utmost importance
that we stay vigilant and that we
over time
re-tighten the sanctions
therefore as i said we develop now a
system of rolling sanctions to make sure
that neither loopholes nor
circumventions are
necessary anymore
um you were speaking about
the russian ships
we just made sure that ships with the
russian flag cannot enter european ports
anymore
you were
speaking
about
other parts of the sanctions for example
the topic of the banking sector
here indeed we are looking now into
spare bank deeper and more closely
so
the
matter of sanction is a question of
really searching
all over uh the relationship
that exists still with russia in the
economic field as well as in the
financial field to make sure that we
raise the stake and we raise the price
for putin to pay for his atrocious war
you started your question um with the
attack today on completely innocent
people waiting for a train
and yes i have seen pictures and it is
atrocious and there are almost no words
for it and i was
deeply shocked to see that
on pieces left from the shelling
the russian had written
for our children
the cynical
behavior
has almost
no
no benchmark anymore no measure anymore
it is unbelievable what happens there
and therefore it is also so important
that this world stands up the fact that
russia has been suspended from the human
rights council
is an important signal too that not only
those who are now closely working to
support ukraine
in this war but also those who are put
perhaps a little a little bit further
away stand up raise their voice and make
clear no this is inacceptable and this
has consequences in the world order and
uh the place that russia has in the
world orders
thank you very much for the question